the slow zone they still called it even
though the weird limit on speed had been
lifted the name was the name and it
carried a sense of strangeness and doom
with it most of his work was inside
medina heading out into the vacuum was a
rare thing and now he was here he didn't
like it much he kept turning away from
the job to look out into the black it
had been almost the end of his first
week on the job before he realized he
was looking for the milky way and that
he kept looking because it wasn't there
hey guys pete here got a really short
expanse season 6 video today just to
follow up on the one i put out last week
while we still don't know if it's going
to be a short season we do know when
we're going to find out today there was
an announcement for new york comic-con
2021 the statement says amazon prime
will delight attendees with virtual
panels from new series the legend of vox
machina the wheel of time and i know
what you did last summer plus returning
fan favorites the expanse and hannah
about the expanse panel it says the cast
and creators come together to give fans
a first look at the highly anticipated
sixth and final season of the expanse on
amazon prime video on twitter the
expanse writers account confirmed that
there would be a first look and there's
an announcement with the date and time
and our first image from the upcoming
season so in just about three weeks on
friday october 8th this is all happening
last year around the same time they did
the same thing there was an expanse
panel at the 2020 new york comic-con
where the cast previewed season five
with the writers and showrunner and in
the middle of that they premiered the
full trailer they announced the release
date and they explained the schedule of
releasing the first three episodes at
once to binge and then following that up
with weekly releases instead of dropping
them all at once like they did with
season four at that time they didn't
announce that the show was renewed for
the sixth season instead they announced
that in november and that's when we
learned that it would be the final
season this year we can expect the panel
to be similar and if they are planning
on releasing it in december again then
we'll probably also get a full trailer
perhaps if it's later then we'll get a
first look teaser just to have something
at comic-con and then a more substantial
look about two months before the
premiere the article that i cited in my
last video talking about the rumor that
there might only be six episodes did say
that they could confirm that
post-production would be done at the end
of november and that they still expected
it to be released in december or
possibly early january if that
information is correct then we can
expect that this year's comic-con will
be similar to what we saw last year and
that we'll get a good look at season six
in just three weeks the most exciting
part of all of this was just getting a
look at the announcement with a shot of
the rossi near the ringgate station in
the middle of the slow zone you can see
that there's been some changes made to
it and i won't spoil things by telling
you what that is what's going on with it
if you haven't read babylon's ashes but
can say that it's exciting to see for
someone who has read it i'll talk about
this some more in my pinned comment
underneath the spoiler tag you'll
remember that at the end of season 5 the
breakaway martian fleet were moving
through the laconia gate and the free
navy had taken control of the slow zone
in medina station of course the barkeith
ran into some trouble but most of the
fleet made it through and we saw through
cortazar when he was talking to sobater
just before the ship went dutchman and
disappeared that some people had already
arrived on the planet when season six
opens we can expect that the free navy
will be controlling the slow zone and
therefore access to all the ring gates
not a lot of new information but we're
getting close one way or the other since
that rumor about the final season being
short is going around it's nice that
we'll probably learn for sure early next
month as mentioned last year they put
out the release schedule though i don't
remember seeing the episode run times
until later i don't think those showed
up until much closer to the premiere i
said i was gonna make it short and i'm
gonna stick to that let me know in the
comments what you think about this first
look image and what you're hoping to
find out at the comic-con panel please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching i'll talk to
you soon